can you tell us what the uh of the other  way of being raised would be in  Hollywood where your parents are super  super famous right what was that like  well let me put it like this right  um out of all the  out of all the you know out of all my  peers I ever had growing up from you  know the time I was in kindergarten to  all the way through High School  um I was probably the least spoiled kid  that I ever met right like there were  kids you know that not had been the son  of like a successful like dentist you  know or an orthodontist that I went to  school with and they were spoiled rotten  you know what I'm saying  my parents could have spoiled me more  than anybody and I was the least spoiled  okay because they they caught they  raised me consciously knowing that if we  give this kid everything he's gonna grow  up to be you know a loser or just a  piece of [ __ ] or just have no work ethic  because he's already been giving every  he's already been given everything